Before this video begins, I have an important announcement
You wanna hear about this (Oh?)
There's a new app called Nimses
where if you download it, your life will become a social media game.
As soon as you register,
every single minute of your life will be quantified
into nim, a currency
And this is collected from since you register,
not just how much you use your phone
or what you spend in the app.
So the more nims you have, the more
powerful and influence you get.
Now just imagine it for a second...
if everyone downloaded this app...
It's a pretty insane concept.
I don't think I've heard about any idea
anywhere like this.
Except in sci-fi scenarios
Nimses users could potentially buy
real things in the future using their Nims,
Like your next Tesla, or your next
represent.com/pewdiepie merch collection (real smooth)
There are social roles within the app
such as user and icon.
You get your Nims, you own them, and then
you save them, and everyone sees how many Nims
you have.
So you can be a regular user or you can
actually try and grow your influence and reach
the unreachable icon status.
Just imagine if everyone was using this
I think it's a pretty insane idea,
and I'm really curious to see how it's
gonna work out.
So, sign up, follow me there
Invite your friends as well
cuz then you get more Nims.
The idea is to turning human life
into a source of financial capital.
I'm really really rEaLlY curious about this
Enter the code PEWDIEPIE so I get referral Nims
Thank you very much
Check it out and follow me there
I'll be using Nimses from now on.
Let's get on with the video...
*Poo News Moosic*
Good evening, I'm Mary Ham
and welcome to "Ham News".
*Pew News Intro*
"Pew News"
First of all, Mary Ham News
have reached the highest ratings it has ever gotten.
Oh boy, all the comments have been
sO supportive. (BRING BACK POPPY GLORIA)
"NO ONE LIKES YOU MARY HAM
"I'm not a fan of Mary Ham"
"No I refuse to watch with Mary Ham"
"I tHiNk MaRy HaM nEeDs tO bE fIrEd"
"I HATE YOU" *glasses fall*
"I hate you Mary Ham get Poppy Gloria back"
Poppy Gloria is dead, ok?
She did an oopsie.
Get it into your thick skulls already
She ain't coming back
Yes, I may have killed her,
but that doesn't prove I'm innocent.
Now let's get into the news.
Our first story comes from KSI (kzeh)
Who has now responded to Deji, his brother,
calling him out.
In not just one video,
but tWo vIdEoS.
And KSI has now, finally
responded. (don't all youtubers)
"So you thought, going on Logan Paul's podcast
to talk about me was the best way to
branch out from my bro.
If you went on there to talk about
something else,
then fine.
But you didn't.
It was all pretty much about me.
The best way, Dej, to branch out
from me, is to not talk about me at all.
And then on top of that,
make good quality content
that your fans would enjoy."
Logan: Does he have a god complex?
Is it an ego?
Deji: Yeah, that's what I mean.
His ego is insane (he's not lying tho)
Like his diss track to Quadeca,
he compared himself to Ares."
BRUUUUH
Maybe Deji has some points that are fair,
maybe KSI wasn't great brother or whatever.
But I think KSI did a really good job
explaining his side of the situation.
KSI: You can talk to me, especially if you're
having dark thoughts, or
just feeling low.
I'm always here for you whether
we're on good terms, or bad terms.
Whenever you message me, I always
reply Dej.
I want you to succeed in
everything you do, but Deji, man,
you have to communicate with me.
Else, how else am I going to know
how you're feeling?
Popp... Mary Ham: And I gotta say, like, Deji's video
had midrolls on it.
He comes with this video out of nowhere
with a video that has midrolls on it,
42 minutes, right after the whole
Tati situation became a huge viral thing.
AAAND...
Uuuuuh...
EEEEEH, UUUUH
It's kind of hard to side with someone that
puts that perspective on it,
especially when KSI made a lot of good points.
I'm sorry.
KSI also said that, in his video,
he's gonna donate all the ad revenue to
suicide prevention charities, and in light of
Deji being in the dark place.
BUT THEN, out of nowhere, Logan Paul decided
to anime laugh
HUH HUH HUh
and claim the video!
"HAHAHAHA, F you puѕѕy"
"If you don't ads, it's because it's being claimed
by Logan Paul's network."
Logan, what the frick are you doing?
Do you want people to hate you?
What is this???
Money going to suicide prevention charities
Logan Paul: AHAHA
Now, it's clear that Logan Paul didn't know this.
And he said, I jumped the gun on that one.
I'll make sure the automatic claim is removed.
KSI is still a РР.
This whole situation is just dumb.
It's dummy dumb.
Dummy dumb dumb.
Now let's go into
Probably the biggest noise I've ever heard
Jesus
And it's about the Steven Crowder vs Carlos Maza situation
Put this head here and the other head here
And here they are
It all started with Vox news reporter, Carlos Maza
Who wrote in his Twitter "So I have pretty thick skin
when it comes to online harrassment,
but something has been really bothering me"
He pointed out how whenever Steven Crowder debunks his videos,
He also ridicules his sexual orientation and ethnicity.
"Look before we get to the video, uh, with our favorite, favorite lispy sprite from Vox"
*in mocking tone* "It's ridiculous! It's bonkers!"
"You're being given a free pass as a crappy write because you're gay"
"...his little queer graph there"
*laughing*
"Well now the graph is queer?"
"...violence, filth"
"Ok so the little queer can eat his chips all nonchalantly
"...mister queer eating chips on the Vox channel"
"chip chip chip chip, bet you can't eat just one, like dicks"
"This is what mister gay Vox wants to do"
"Mister lispy queer from Vox"
Now Steven Crowder, for those who don't know,
is a right-wing YouTuber
And apparently, according to himself,
He's the "Biggest Conservative Channel on YouTube"
Wait, is that true? How many does Ben Shapiro have?
1.7!!
Bruuh
Maza also pointed out how he got doxxed and he got a bunch of text messages
Saying "debate steven crowder"
Now I blurred the numbers, but I like how Maza
complains about being doxxed and then he doxxes all these people
Regardless, alright, he also points out how YouTube's policies
against harassment and bullying are not aligned with the comments that Steven has said about him
"That being said, I'm not mad at Crowder"
Well that's a f*cking lie
Are you sUre about that?
But he does raise a good point
I mean I haven't even seen this
"Content that is deliberately posted in order to humiliate someone"
"Content that makes hurtful and negative personal comments/videos about that person"
That's so vague, but it does apply doesn't it
He does have a point
Carlos also pointed out how Steven Crowder sells a shirt
that says "Socialism is for 'figs'"
Although it's one of those "edgy jokes"
That it can be interpreted either way and he sees it has "Socialism is for fags"
Now this shirt will be important later, ok? So let's just remember this shirt for now
I have to say, I think it is good that Maza speaks out
There is a problem with people
There is a big issue online where people with audiences criticize each other
which they should be able to do
but then the audience joins in and makes the whole place toxic
with harassment, doxxing, etc. of these individuals
This is obviously not ok and if ANYONE EVER DOES IT FOR ME
then you can eat the fat lard, ok? I want nothing to do with it
Obviously, most people don't want this
Crowder has spoken out against this as well
But it is a larger issue that, nonetheless,  deserves to be brought up
So, I think it's good he spoke out.
However
The timing of all of this is pretty interesting
Obviously, this was posted one day before Pride Month
The clips that showed about Steven Crowder making fun of Maza
Were not new ones, these are older clips
Which made it seem like this was a deliberate attack to go after Steven as much as possible
But also, in a way, if I was going after someone that was way bigger than me
Yes, technically he works under Vox which is a billion dollar company
But he didn't tweet this out through Vox, ok? He tweeted at it on his personal Twitter
So, if I was Maza I would probably want some sort of support to back me up as well
So, in a way, I can understand that
It just seems like the whole tone is more coming across as aggressive
As opposed to just wanting to out him on his behavior
Maza is not just going after Crowder, he's also going after YouTube directly
I am Poppy Gloria all along